this episode is brought to you by our
patrons over at patreon.com journeyto
micro our patreon supporters are the
reason videos like this can exist and
right now we're trying to hit a new goal
of 900 monthly patrons once we hit that
goal we're going to be making a special
microscopists react video where a few of
us from the microcosmos team are going
to react to some of the good and not so
good microscopy that we've seen in TV
shows and movies I think it's going to
be fun if you'd like to join community
and help us hit our goal you can sign up
for just $2 at patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
you can even picture yourself spending a
nice fall day in a canoe your hand
passing through Waters that feel cool
and refreshing against your skin but
then perhaps something else brushes up
against your hand too a light touch that
you ignore the first time and then the
second time as well even the third time
maybe you manage to keep your composure
though the movement is more insistent
and squirming than the first few
contacts and as it keeps happening you
realize you have to see what it is so
you peek into the water and there they
are worms lots of them and their bodies
can tell us more about those Waters than
you might even want to
[Music]
know the worms themselves are not that
scary though for from what we've learned
we imagine that identifying them is
going to be kind of a nightmare these
worms are members of the genus naus and
even though there are only roughly 30 na
species we're not sure exactly which one
we're looking at here that ambiguity
feels a little in congruent with the
worm that we see this is not a
particularly subtle creature to look at
there are large squiggles and bright
colors but the specific feature that
scientists use to determine what species
they are looking at is
this those are tiny hairs better known
as Kitty and as you can see they're
quite small and the number of features
you could use to describe them seems
minimal yet scientists have to rely on
these tiny structures to try and apply a
name tag to the worms they are studying
in the words of one paper the
differences between these Kitty are
quote often subtle inconsistent and even
over overlapping between nominal species
honestly sounds like a nightmare to me
James our master of microscopes usually
finds these worms in the ponds around
him they're very common and they're also
very useful just in a kind of creepy way
because these worms dance and not to
insult them or anything but their dances
are kind of unsettling to
watch the worms are partially buried in
the sediment but part that we can see
well they're hard to miss they look like
a hallucination you might conjure up of
the Rocket's performing choreography
inspired by an Edvard monk painting but
the odd thing is that this dancing this
is what makes the worms useful to James
if the worms are dancing like this it
means that there's a lot of oxygen
dissolved in the water when the oxygen
concentration starts to go down though
the worms will start to emerge further
from the sediment and as the levels keep
going down the worms keep rising and
rising in the water until they are right
under the water line and as they rise
they stop
dancing so for James who is often
looking out for organisms who might
prefer a low oxygen environment the
dancing worms are his own biological
oxygen meter helping him gauge the
conditions and its effects on the
creatures he's looking after and while
this is very neat and very useful for
James it is also a bit of a mystery
because we have no idea why they do this
we've looked through papers and tried to
find an explanation but we only have our
guesses James thinks that their dance is
most likely some kind of way to filter
the water around them for food but if
any of you have an explanation we would
love to hear it now this dancing isn't
the first time that someone has used
worms from this genus to understand the
waters around them in fact Nas worms
have been an important part of a
widespread scientific effort to
understand something far more
horrific between 1995 and 1996
researchers ventured to a lake near the
village of young on off in Ukraine to
find worms The Village had been
evacuated nearly a decade before emptied
of people and filled with radiation
following the explosion of the Chernobyl
nuclear power plant in
1986 but plenty of animals remained and
scientists wanted to know what the
effect of radiation in Chernobyl had
been on them and the ecosystem around
them some scientists looked at mice
others looked at carp and catfish these
scientists chose worms after all they
are incredibly important in aquatic
ecosystems growing to large populations
that help transport and transform
organic matter throughout their watery
world so they gathered worms in the lake
near Chernobyl including two species of
naos worms and then they gathered the
same species from a lake 20 km away
these Lakes were similar in many ways
similar temperatures similar chemical
compositions the major difference of
course was the radiation the sediments
near Chernobyl were loaded with
radioactive strontium around 55 times
more than that in the distant Lake and
the worms themselves were getting dosed
with around 20 times more radiation in
that contaminated Lake that radiation
broke up bits of the worm's DNA leaving
fragments that were then patched back up
but not perfectly the scientists could
see the mistakes left behind in the
worm's chromosomes it's one one thing to
find a mistake or two in the cells that
can happen spontaneously but what the
scientists found was more than double
the rate of that kind of mistake leaving
behind a buildup of aberration embedded
genetically within the worm and the
scientists also found something else a
change of behavior in the worms nothing
like the dance we saw earlier but
something that's unexpected for these
worms sex now Naas worms can reproduce
sexual but they tend not to in fact this
is part of why they're difficult to
study compared to worms and related
genuses often those worms are
distinguished by the shape of their
genitals but Naas worms are so rarely
engaged in sexual reproduction that they
don't often have what scientists
delicately describe as quote fully
developed sexual apparatus that lack of
obvious genitalia makes it difficult to
identify them and yet in the contamin
ated Lake Naas worms were more likely to
pursue sexual reproduction compared to
their counterparts a strategy likely
meant to help introduce variations in
their genome that might allow them to
adapt to the new stresses of their
environment particularly that radiation
decades later perhaps that lake is
filled with the worms born of those many
couplings and maybe they're there
dancing in the sediment while they bear
the genetic Legacy of a catastrophic
event thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us these people on
the screen right now they are some of
our patreon patrons we really really
like making this show and we have a lot
of people who support us and we're so
grateful for them so if you want to
thank anybody for the existence of this
YouTube channel these are some of the
names of those people and if you would
like to join them you can can do that by
going to patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]